hello everybody
my name is james monroy and i'm going to
present to you today on leveraging
python
and open source for data science on the
buy side
before i get any further though i need
to show you these
two slides of important information if
you'd like to read them
please pause the video
okay so just to introduce myself first
uh i've been working in finance for
about 10 years
all of which was being at man group
before that i was a physicist
over the last 10 years i've worked in a
number of quant development teams
and i've run a number of quant
development teams for ahl
and the last two years i've been cto for
my nhl
so over that period as well over the
last 10 years uh
the story has mostly been a python one
uh for me and my team
so i'll talk a little bit about why we
use python it's not just because of data
science
i'll talk about the open source story
for us what matters for us in industry
then i'll talk about how those uh or how
those address the problem that we're
trying to solve
which is delivering research ideas and
then delivering those
into production into trading
mention briefly some of the compute
requirements around that
and what we've learned there
and then how we connect simulation or
the back test
the uh the test of your model and
trading the model
and how we connect those two things then
i'll also talk a bit about
the story we've seen around data over
the last five and six years which makes
this data science
interesting area so interesting right
now
man group is a global investment
management firm focused on delivering
performance
for its clients we're a set of diverse
investment specialists these include ahl
numeric glg gpm and frm
nhl the one i've been working with is a
fully systematic investment manager
amongst other things that means
everything is fully automated
from data through to trading
hl's been around for over 30 years and
has
over 35 billion dollars of aum at the
moment
numeric is more of a fundamentally
driven quantitative asset manager they
have both long only
and alternative equity and credit
strategies
they're best based in boston grg is a
discretionary investment manager
so they're focused much more on human
interaction
and making decisions humans making
decisions based on
rich data and sometimes quantitative
techniques as well
gpm whilst gpm is a private markets
investment manager
they do things like real estate and debt
from is more of an advisor they're an
investment specialist
they provide managed accounts co-mind
co-mingled strategies
and other advisory relationships
um hl is very technology focused
um and much of the front office
groups are as well but hl's got a long
track record here
we do a whole bunch of things in this
area we sponsor this
conference um and we also sponsor
the london monthly meetups at least when
they do happen
unfortunately obviously that hasn't been
so possible this year
but the monthly meetups in london happen
in an auditorium across the road from us
normally
we have fancy technology in the office
like this liquid cooled
machine learning desk uh we have fancy
technology in the data centers as well
and we support things like
coding competitions and hackathons we
have
external speakers coming to talk to us
and we support lots of open source
so what's the story with python and us
so
python we adopted not long after i
joined the company
and at that time it wasn't peerless when
it comes to data science
i think it is now but it wasn't peerless
back then it was very much a competitor
with matlab and r and maybe a few other
things
but it was much more about the wider
sets of use cases that it helps to solve
things like doing data transformation
loading
with its wise supportive databases all
the good
web service tools um the way it would be
good in production
and helping us to write our trading
systems except
for where things are low latency or need
more high performance stuff
visualization reporting and batch jobs
have all been good use cases for python
as well
so for us it was much more of a general
story
now i think we're really happy with the
choice given it's
super and first class as a data science
language as well
and if we were asked at the moment or if
we were to evaluate other languages like
julia
i think it would be because of the
missing development tooling
and some of these other use cases that
maybe aren't
whilst they're possible in the language
maybe aren't so well supported
by the wide range of open source
technology available
okay so there are a couple of practices
we use internally that helps us sort of
deal with python at scale
and i think um you know especially
continuous integration
and python really go hand in hand
because of this weakness around
refactoring python
um because it's a dynamically typed
language you really need to
be testing your code all the time you
really need to be integrating your
changes all the time
because you need that because you need
to know that your changes you do
make continue to work for everyone so
continuous integration is a key practice
for us
and given the um scale of the operation
here where we're approaching
seven million lines of python
[Music]
hundreds of builds um
we need to keep merging those changes in
we need to keep maintaining all of that
code
and we saw this as valuable uh recently
when we moved to python 3
years ago and uh
that really helped us out being able to
make changes across tens of thousands of
files
and make sure that everything still
worked so continuous integration is
about merging your changes in up
frequently it's about automating the
build and running the test all the time
continuous deployment is more about
being ready to release all the time
not using long lead branches or having
long lived
gap between what you're developing and
what you have in production
it's about automating as much as
possible whilst we're not completely
automated to production
it's definitely a goal and
we've got very close now where we just
change the config file
and the new version of the code runs in
production
so and we also try to release as much as
possible and that's a key
uh payoff for us we're continuously
changing not just the build but all the
way to production
continuously integrating our changes and
allows us to keep up
with the state of the art another thing
is we've actually trialled
you know almost 900 open source packages
for python
which just makes it and we don't use
nearly that many but we do use hundreds
of packages or open source and it just
makes it
a really good base to work from
and that's really the first inevitable
thing about
python linux and a data science stack is
that you're inevitably using
open source and
culturally as well i think there's an
advantage you know in some places
there's this not invented here
syndrome but there's an advantage when
you're willing to use high quality tools
invented externally and willing to
figure out how to plug them together
willing to understand why they exist and
what use they serve
and because of things like
standardization of licenses it's so easy
to try all this stuff
much easier than with proprietary tools
where you have to get demos
trial licenses so open source is just
the way to go
for trialing software
and then you also i think get this
advantage about separation of concerns
and it used to be the case that you'd
get these massive sort of stacks of
technology delivered by
places like sun microsoft
then you'd build everything else
internally nowadays you can build things
out of
almost like lego with all these open
source tools
that's been a real advantage for us as
well and then you also get people
who know what they're doing because
they've used pandas numpy before
etc what does this look like for us
well we see uh open source permeating a
lot of the stacks
obviously there's putting it all
together at the top of the stack
that means we're delivering our own
tools
our own analytics our own visualizations
and
and in particular our own data platform
but most of the bottom layers of the
stack
are really well serviced by open source
now and we see this rising tide
excuse me we see this rising tide of
open source technology
uh all through the layers you know from
compute to storage process management
we're running a large compute cluster
with spark all the python development
tooling
all the open source libraries reaching
higher and higher levels of abstraction
you know in the data platform now we
have things like apache beam
helping us to run our data pipeline and
we in
and whilst a numerical optimizes um
probably still the best there of
proprietary we're getting you know
better and better
numerical optimizers available as open
source tools
and whilst a lot of the quant tooling we
have for say pricing asset classes
uh will be proprietary they'll be our
own
uh we are seeing quite you know more and
more
quantity available uh open source as
well
okay but then there's also contributing
to open source and one is
just the ability to give back is awesome
um it's not quite a monetization thing
for us
because it's not you know our business
to open source things
it's our business to make money for our
clients
so whereas other companies might open
source something to help
seed adoption to help get buy-in from
developers around the world
that's not really a thing for us but it
just means that we're giving back
instead
um but there are advantages for us as
well it's not
it's not um just about us being
charitable here we
are not maintaining patches internally
we'd rather contribute
upstream in the source package that
reduces our own tech debt
we get better separation of concerns
when we can use upstream packages
which we help support or where we open
source our own packages
it helps enforce separation from your
own infrastructure
and it helps you separate out what
you're doing so you deliver a package
which does something in particular
uh you get help obviously if you open
source packages other people
will contribute and they're able to fork
and take it in the own direction that
they like as well
and you know if people are using pandas
and your own tools
uh then that helps skill people up and
it helps you hire the best talent
so just a few examples of things we have
open source there's detail
which is a pandas slicer and dicer
visualizer
and gives you basic basic statistics as
well you can run it from notebooks you
can run it independently
notebooker is a way to trivially go from
notebooks to a reporting system
it uses a the netflix library that helps
you parameterize notebooks
to pass arguments in so you can say for
instance run a notebook for a different
model parameterization a different
market in our case
might be another example of where you'd
add a parameter into a notebook
and generate reports and you can
generate beautiful reports because you
can shrink the code out the way and just
have the formatted report of the
notebook
partial testing helps us with our
continuous integration story
we record the coverage from the tests
and then we only run the tests that
change
you need to run because your code has
changed
arctic is an open source tool that
it's based on our tool that we use
internally
to store tick data time series data
there's not
i don't think there's a lot of good
solutions for tick storage out there in
the open source world
arctic is one of them um is one of the
good solutions
adero is an internal app we use uh
for 360 feedback and helping to develop
the team that's now
open source so so everyone can use it pi
test plugins is one of my favorites
as a professional python developer you
write a lot of tests
you're doing integration testing you
need to fixture that
with the right tools it might be
databases might be web servers might be
git repositories might be virtual
environments
this will let you do that in a very
small number of lines of code often just
a decorator
on the test function okay
so what's the problem we're trying to
solve here well we're basically trying
to go from
idea to production and we're trying to
prove it's valuable
we're trying to develop that idea
and then we have to go through this
process of implementing it and trading
it
so you've got some new idea some new
data the research step takes some in
sample part of that data
and then let's the quant or researcher
or data scientist work on that data
figure out what's valuable once there's
an idea there that we
think we could trade we excuse me
we take it to a review phase that's
where you use out of sample data
compare it to the in-sample results
compare it to a threshold that you've
set
and then you may discard the idea or you
may continue to implementation
this in-sample outside and pull process
it's not something that just happens in
academia
this is a critical for getting the
answer right in the real world as well
there's such a risk of overfitting here
implementation is where we take that you
know maybe a script
a simulation of what could happen and
we uh make it possible to run that thing
in production
uh 24 hours a day completely unattended
and with all the necessary diagnostics
we need to check it's working properly
we then trade that thing and it's
important to include this trade step
in this iterative process because it's
something that's constantly reviewed
so there's whether the model actually
predicts
outcomes in the market and there's also
whether
our simulation or what we wanted to
trade matches production
so those two factors are continuously
monitored after we take it into
production
then the process starts again and this
you can think of this as hierarchical as
well so you may construct a new fund
as a top level idea it might be formed
of several smaller ideas
those smaller ideas would be projects
for quantitative researchers
and those those researchers will you
know every day go through this kind of
loop
a shorter version of this loop as they
try and develop these ideas
and then at the end of the day you're
delivering this stuff into
a trading system trading systems
join these other bits together they take
data from vendors pricing
other sorts of data they send orders to
the market
once those orders are filled those fills
need to be recorded very carefully
in a books and records system so called
the back office
and then we also pull diagnostics out of
this blue box because we don't want this
blue box to be a black box we want to be
able to introspect it
we want to see what's happening because
it's only for understanding what's
happening that we can improve it
if we drill into this blue box
uh you can think of it as a pipeline
internally
now this pipeline may be extremely tight
for like a hft phone or it may be quite
extensive
for a large bank or for large asset
managers
it starts with data so it comes in from
the street
from the internet and then it's
transformed normalized and processed
ready for prediction step
that signal generation is a prediction
step but once you have a prediction on a
market
you need to combine it with all those
markets you need to understand where
each fund is at
what positions they can hold need to
understand what your limits are
so there's this whole trade generation
and optimization step you need to
understand how to get to your target
position
most efficiently that optimization step
is therefore also critical
order management is all about risk
limits
regulatory limits um making sure that
the fund gets what it needs making sure
that we meet any exchange limits it's
all about the constraints of the system
and it's more like a checking process
once it passes through order management
goes to execution and execution's job is
to fill that order
as cheaply as possible so if you think
about it there are actually three places
quant models exist
in trading systems well
there's a fourth um but i haven't
really touched on it here and that the
way but and you could consider it part
of signal generation as well
it's how you go from data to something
you can use
you could consider for instance natural
language processing as a fourth step in
the data
i've i've assumed that that's part of
signal generation here
signal generation is just about
predicting individual markets if you
like or collections of markets
trade generation um because there's lots
of optimization
and it's not um there's not one way to
do it
it's a uh it's a step you need to
optimize yourself a step you need to
understand and improve yourself that is
a quant models there as well
and then an execution a much tighter
loop there
but it's all about how you how you do
that much tighter loop
low latency loop of getting data from
the market deciding how to get the rest
of the order into the market
as cheaply as possible the execution
algorithm
okay so those current models
right they need consistent apis so that
you can deliver lots and lots of them
into production
so you can think of that as like a quant
container you've got ways to submit
orders you've got ways to get data
you've got risk management controls
you've got configuration which might
include weights to markets
weights to signals even model parameters
that you might be refitting on some
schedule
we've got diagnostics that are coming
out that you're using to understand
whether the model is working correctly
and you might be requesting commit
computes from
things like spark clusters which we have
in research and trading
so this idea of a quant container and
it's the way you deliver
your strategies to production and you
have uh
many surrounding systems that support
this process
so i've mentioned simulation a few times
and
there's a particular way we think about
simulation and trading and really we try
and make the code be shared
some companies will take python script
generated by an
analyst or something you know in
whatever language they've used and they
might have several languages their
analysis using
and they'll rewrite it in c or java
and if you're trying to do data science
or you're trying to do machine learning
that can be really complicated because
you might not have the right level of
machine learning tooling in that
language
we've definitely taken the approach for
that reason
and for the reason of actually having an
interpretable system
that your quants can also read they can
look at prod code and see what it does
of not recoding of just sort of taking
that
existing code and making sure it's fit
for production
and that correspondence we see all the
way through the stack as well so we try
and use the same data where we can
sometimes you can't because you've
bought historical data but you're
collecting live data
but as much as possible it's a match api
can be the same though
we can definitely have the same code for
signal generation broader management now
there can be an extensive order
management system
might be too slow to run for simulation
you need your simulations to be fast
but the calculation could be the same
execution
obviously you're not really trading for
simulation
but you can take the commissions you can
take the data
of where you've learned about the market
impact from each trade
how much it costs to trade each market
and you can use that in your simulation
and get really accurate results for how
much your trade execution costs
are so all of this needs
a relatively extensive compute system
some of which is possible to put in the
cloud some of which is not
one of the things the cloud's not great
at is high performance compute clusters
so whilst you can scale up sort of map
produce jobs in the cloud
not every job is amenable to that and
it's useful to have high performance
compute available for your researchers
ideally you want your researchers to
think there's infinite compute available
such that they can just do the job that
they need to do
to develop the best possible models so
we have thousands of calls this is
actually an image from last year
i think we've probably doubled the size
of our cluster since then
thousands of calls and tens of terabytes
of memory
available for researchers to use another
key aspect there
is to have file storage you might think
with this data the growth of data
well that's okay because data's got
cheaper to store
but you can't just have data a data
storage system which is
as slow as the previous generation you
also need to have faster data storage
because you need to get through that
more extensive data faster to do the job
okay so one example of um
traditional day two feet like it's just
price data and that's here tick data
here
and uh this is kind of a well-known
problem in finance and well addressed
uh there are systems for collecting
billions of ticks a day
that we run and
in fact this year we saw over three
billion ticks
during march during when that pandemic
uh the news of the pandemic really
started to affect
the markets
uh you know it's not uncommon for us to
see more than two billion ticks a day
this year with all the volatility
so price data fairly well understood
problem
um still quite an extensive challenge
here for instance a nice feature of this
plot is you can see when markets open so
asia opening here early in the morning
and then further countries in asia
before europe opens here at eight
o'clock
and then the us opens at 2 30 p.m our
time
so you can see the pattern of price data
throughout the day and when it comes in
however the story over the last five or
six years has been about a sort of
growth of types of data set
that are amenable to be used for
prediction
both because there's new data sets being
collected and sold
and because we have new methods yeah
methods that allows us to use
text data images other sorts of data
so we have things like weather data
credit card transactions
news review data
and we can use all of that data now to
try and predict markets
one of the key challenges though is
actually mapping that data back to what
you might trade
so you might have data on suppliers for
a company
maybe samsung or lg is supplying apple
with displays i don't know
maybe that's changing through time maybe
samsung's going away and the new iphone
uses a different type of display
so that data therefore you might be
collecting that across a whole bunch of
companies
so you might trade apple directly
through its common stock that would be
listed on an exchange
and you need to know where it's listed
to send it to trade
and you may have a number of idea ids
for that common stock
different data providers use like
bloomberg or a common id like cdl or
internal ids
or instead of trading a stock directly
or trade you might trade the option on
the stock
or you might trade it as part of a
collection of data
that you've got for the index for the s
p
500 you might trade the future or the
option on the future
or the common stock might be might be
part of an etf portfolio and you might
trade the option on that
so there's just so much going on here
with how you might trade something
and also how you have to go from what
might be relatively unstructured data
with strings which might include company
names might include the products of the
company not the company name like iphone
for apple
uh mapping that all back to the thing
you might actually trade and this is all
a time series right this is a snapshot
here
by reality this is changing through time
and if you're holding hundreds or
thousands of positions
this is something that becomes a
management problem that you have to
solve
and it's not something your data vendors
are best apt at because you're joining
all this data yourself
okay the eagle alpha is like a connector
or aggregator of data
and this is kind of the growth they've
seen in the number of data sets they've
indexed
and there's all sorts of things you can
see you know esg data
employment data sentiment data and it's
really grown over the last five or six
years the amount of data that is
available in the market
and that's one of the key stories for us
as well
uh if you wanted more evidence here we
go we've got number of jobs available on
the left here and how that's grown up to
2018
it would have grown more over the last
couple of years as well
and then the amount of data spending on
the buy side that's growing
and i know these are estimates this data
is a bit old
but really it has grown that much i can
guarantee it so
the uh this has been a real key story
so together we have this sort of data
science story
let me conclude for you we have this
data science story we've seen expand
over the last five six years
last 10 years in part we've seen python
be a key tool for that
we've seen open source being a key tool
for that
internally and that's helped us address
a trading system and getting quant
models
into the trading system and now with the
explosion of data
we have many more of these quant models
to deploy
and so we're really leveraging those
technologies
um to help us solve that problem
i also touched on compute and uh the
nature of our relationship with
simulation and trading
um and talked a bit about the company as
well so i hope that was interesting
um i hope that has been a little bit of
a
insight into this part of the industry
if you'd like to learn more
then please go to the ahl website or the
man website
hr website has uh videos that tell
tell you a lot about what we've been
doing man institute
on the man website uh has investment
management
video uh articles and videos and
podcasts
uh if you're interested in that there's
also technology articles
please go to github have a look at our
open source offering
and please follow us on mancontech thank
you very much for listening
have a good day and stay safe